i think the number one skill
that helped me be a strong founder
especially in the early days of building
our business is the ability to sell and
i think i'm blessed in the sense that
that's just one of my intuitive
superpowers it's something my dad worked
on with me as i was growing up he he was
really
focused on my ability to articulate
he thought that was really important
i ended up taking
a business communications class at
michigan but to be totally honest i
didn't find it very valuable half the
time was spent doing kind of public
speaking half the time was spent
literally like digital communication
like how to write an email and i found
that to to be tough tough as in like not
helpful but yeah i mean sales i would
say is that if you are trying to elevate
yourself as a professional in any way
not just as an entrepreneur just in your
career you find yourself selling
yourself
far more times than you realize so like
just even talking about a business when
we were starting morning brew we're
talking about a startup that was a media
company media companies are generally
not
venture backable so you can't raise from
institutions
uh we had a newsletter that's all we had
we had 30 000 subscribers at the time
we weren't making any money but we had
to raise money in order to possibly get
to a place of making money and so
selling investors on why
a 21 year old and a 19 year old who have
a media company where media companies
are generally not profitable businesses
and we weren't making money yet and by
the way it's not really a media company
it's a newsletter we have to sell them
on why they should put their hard-earned
money in our business
we had to sell our initial employees on
why they should leave their steady jobs
to join a business that's making zero
dollars and we had to sell advertisers
because that was the first way we made
money as a business we had to sell
advertisers like
discover card large financial
institutions on why they should even
bother wasting their time on a company
that reaches 30 000 people versus
allocating that time to thinking about
say a television commercial that reads
reaches millions of people
and so i'd say that is
the number one meta skill i'd actually
argue it's a meta skill even like in
personal life not just professional life
i've i've heard a lot of people say that
that you know
the the skill of selling is kind of yeah
is well one of the one of the most
useful skills you can have but i've
always kind of wondered and i never
quite followed this thought of like what
does what does that actually mean
like i wouldn't say i'm good at selling
but i've i guess i have sold stuff in
the past and i just don't really think
of
selling as like a thing um you sell
yourself on youtube every time you post
a video like and this is actually an
interesting thing and i've thought a lot
about this is
what's the difference between sales and
or selling and storytelling
and my view is just if something comes
off as selling it's just shitty
storytelling
uh and and
and so my view is like why do people
watch your videos for a long time why
did you just hit three million
subscribers on youtube when there's a
bunch an abundance of content because
you're not the first person to talk
about topics related to productivity to
bettering yourself right you have found
a way to storytell
in a way that captivates people and
keeps them engaged so you are
innately good at storytelling i just
don't think i think it is quite natural
and intuitive to you it doesn't feel
like work to script and then
uh deliver that in front of a camera you
couldn't be where you are today without
being exceptional storytelling how do
people get better at this it's a great
question um my answer would be it's a
combination of practice
of
shadowing and feedback and of
understanding the fundamentals of what
it means to storytell well
so going in reverse order
i think
that they're they're tried and true
there's the science to it there's like
tried and true formulas for what is a
captivating story for people uh and so
like for example i'm reading uh the book
creativity inc right now which is the
story of pixar like there are there are
story arcs which is like there is a hero
the hero is on a journey the hero on the
journey experiences a challenge uh in
experiencing the the challenge they go
through adversity
they overcome the challenge and they
reach their goal like that is one story
arc i think there are a number of
formulas this way so at base level i
think
studying the best storytellers of all
time
and studying the formulas that they use
to tell stories is the first step the
second step is what i would say is
the combination of practice and
shadowing and so the example i'll use
for you is in the early days of morning
brew when we had to pitch advertisers on
advertising in our newsletter i had
never sold
in a professional setting anything
before
but i had to do it there was no option
we had to make money
and so i
you know got reps
pitching probably in our first year 250
advertisers on 30-minute calls about who
morningbrew was what we stood for and
why spending your money with us was
worth your time and your money based on
what your goals were and the first pitch
i did probably second pitch probably the
20th pitch i did was really bad but
every time i would take
five to ten minutes after a pitch and
i'd have a reflection period where i
would
write down what are the things that i
think i did well and what is one thing i
would change for the next pitch i do and
i would record every pitch i did as well
so
then thinking about shadowing and
feedback right i was delivering feedback
for myself but a big thing that i did
with our junior sales people when they
joined morning brew
was when they would do a pitch in the
early days i would join them on those
calls so that first of all like i would
do the sales pitch they would listen to
me so they would sponge up that
information we would do that for a few
weeks and then gradually i would hand
off the reins to them where they would
start doing the pitch we would record it
we would listen back to it together
after which by the way for anyone who
hasn't listened to their voice before
and hasn't listened to themselves do a
sales pitch it is going to be
excruciating for you to do the first
time but it is so valuable
i would give them feedback and then they
would
use that feedback the next time and you
know you look at a company like
gong
gong is a multi-billion dollar sales
software company there's a reason it's
such a valuable business so what gog
basically allows you to do is allow
sales orgs to record every sales call
they have and then in in a database
holds all of the sales calls organized
by who the seller was the type of client
that it was and it also will do things
as sophisticated as say what percentage
of the time on the call were you talking
versus what percentage of the time was
the person talking and it will
categorize what were you talking about
almost like you know on youtube how you
can kind of set the chapters of an
episode it does that automatically in
your sales call and so then any seller
can go on to gong and study what are
quote unquote the best calls that have
led to
the conversations that convert their
clients the end of the day there is the
there is this art and science to
understanding what works for you to
storytell in a way that leverages your
strengths um
but also
understanding the science of what works
well and what are kind of like the the
the natural story arcs that people over
the course of time are always attracted
to yeah so learning to sell let's talk
about sales skills
because this goes into specific
knowledge
sales skills are a form of specific
knowledge
really good sales people i think
it you can be trained so it's not to say
you can't learn it uh but
really there's such a thing as a natural
in sales and you run into them all the
time in the industry that i'm in and
when you meet someone who is a natural
at sales you just know that they're
amazing and they're really good at what
they do
that is a form of specific knowledge now
obviously they learned that somewhere
but they didn't learn that in a
classroom setting they learned that
probably in their childhood in a
schoolyard they learned it negotiating
with their parents maybe some of its
genetic component in their dna
so and you can improve it you can read
robert caldini you can go to a sales
training seminar you can do door-to-door
scales which is brutal but will train
you very quickly
so you can definitely improve your sales
skills sales skills but
a lot of sales is this specific
knowledge that you learn just by doing
especially at a very early age
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you